police response to a massacre in uvalde
texas is now being called an abject
failure
stephen mcgraw he's director of the
texas department of public safety use
those exact words at a state senate
hearing he put the blame squarely on
uvalde school district police chief pete
aaron dondo
mcgraw
mccraw rather now says the shooting that
killed 19 students and two teachers
could have been stopped in just minutes
think about that
he also said the classroom keys that
aaron dondo says he was waiting for
weren't even necessary because the door
probably was not even locked omar
villafranca is in uvalde with more on
this story omar good morning to you i
know you attended a meeting where family
members were there i cannot imagine how
furious they must be the more you hear
about this story the worse it gets
good morning gail people were frustrated
at last night's city council meeting
they wanted pete arredondo fired even
the mayor was upset he's saying the city
has been kept in the dark when it comes
to the investigation he told me the last
time he was briefed by troopers was may
25th that's the day after the massacre
bottom line people here want answers and
accountability
he failed us
do not make the same mistake he made and
fell as too pete arredondo wasn't at the
uvalde city council meeting on tuesday
but he was its central focus these kids
didn't choose to be in the line of fire
that's in your job description
who are you protecting
not my sister
the parents
no anger towards the embattled school
district police chief and councilman
seemed to be in abundance the only thing
stopping a hallway of dedicated officers
from in room 111
and 112
was the on-scene commander
who decided to place the lives of
officers before the lives of children
on tuesday texas dps director stephen
mccraw blasted arredondo's actions
arguing that there were enough officers
to neutralize the shooter at robb
elementary within three minutes of his
arrival inside the school the officers
had weapons the children had none the
officers had body armor the children had
none
the officers had training the subject
had none
according to mcgraw's latest timeline
the gunman entered the building at 11 33
a.m arredondo was among several officers
to arrive and wait in the hallway at 11
36.
not until 12 11 pm did he request a
master key to the classrooms where the
gunman opened fire
earlier this month arredondo told the
texas tribune he tried dozens of keys
all of which failed to work adding quote
each time i tried to key i was just
praying
but macross said the door wasn't
properly locked and simply needed to be
opened
no one tried to do that he said and law
enforcement didn't break into the
classroom to kill the shooter until 12
50. the on-scene commander
waited for radio and rifles
then he waited for shields
then he waited for swat
lastly he waited for a key that was
never needed of course we still want
more answers and i'm sure we'll get them
javier casarez's daughter 10 year old
jacqueline is one of the school children
who died in the shooting we spoke to him
after last night's city council meeting
what does justice look like to you
right now i haven't seen any you know i
haven't seen that
it will come
it might not be tomorrow maybe the next
day but it'll come
arodondo testified in a closed-door
hearing in austin yesterday but take a
look at this afterwards he was
surrounded by dps troopers as reporters
were just trying to ask him a few
questions as he went into an elevator
now here in uvalde the city council says
they just can't fire arredondo but
counselors did vote to deny his leave of
absence which means he has to show up to
city council meetings if he misses three
of them they can replace him that move
right there got cheers from the crowd
but their patience is running out nate
omar thank you that's certainly
understandable i quite frankly don't
know how he keeps any job in that city
to be honest with you they did release
some news yesterday that that school is
now going to be torn down officials
deciding no teacher no student should
ever enter that building again they did
that with sandy hillsboro as well yes
yes more details here the more pain and
heartbreak you feel for those families